spring is here which can only mean one
thing mlb the show is back with plenty
of changes for this year's entry here's
everything to know about mlb the show
22. keep your eyes peeled to the channel
as we'll have an official review coming
up real soon and you won't want to miss
it
alright let's get the biggest changes to
the plate first right off the bat
players will have the ability to play
mlb the show 22 on the nintendo switch
the decision to bring the show to
nintendo switch means you can take your
progress with you on the go if you so
choose for the best graphics though you
might opt for the game current gen if
you have a ps5 or series x the baseball
simulator brings a significant amount of
gameplay improvements this time around
starting with custom practice a mode
that i'm definitely going to grow
familiar with in custom practice you can
lock in a certain scenario like let's
say a potential dinger to the center
field then replay it as long as you want
practicing that scenario and testing out
different defensive plays it's a
fascinating change that newer or amateur
players might appreciate especially with
how in-depth the show's gameplay can be
now mlb the show 22 has improved several
aspects of gameplay as the show tends to
balance video game heroics with realism
for example defensive fielding continues
with improvements to animations and
rewarding players who field perfect
balls the better timing you have the
greater chance you'll make a wicked
throw from the outfield in time to tag a
batter out or to pull off an excellent
defensive double play
in the past perfect throws were
exclusive to outfielders trying to cut
off runners but now perfect throws work
for infielders as well so if you have a
stud shortstop you can feel the perfect
throw to home with arm accuracy
dictating the window that you have to
make that play visual changes will also
affect gameplay like dynamic pci range
now the pci is this visual hud indicator
that players will use to adjust their
swing whenever they're trying to hit a
pitch and the pci will shrink now when
near the edge of the strike zone giving
an advantage to pitchers and reducing
lengthy at-bats cause in the past plenty
of at-bats would lead to foul ball after
foul ball drawing out the inning which
could become exhausting but with the new
pci changes there should be more
realistic scenarios playing out when
batting additionally now you can anchor
the pci to certain zones in the strike
zone when batting which will adjust the
sensitivity of your reticle anchoring
the pci will help narrow down with finer
controls on the sides and corners of the
strike zone letting advanced users have
more options on how they want to hit the
show has different game editions and
various upgrade paths which feature
cover athlete shohei otani aka showtime
enjoy a dope stylized cover representing
shohei's love for manga and anime for
those going after the mvp or digital
deluxe editions illustrator takashi
okazaki who according to san diego
studios is also a huge shohei fan went
all out the final result has a wicked
cool manga look to the cover art
now purchasing the more expensive
editions will net you several player
packs of different rarities for diamond
dynasty which is mlb the show's kind of
fantasy team mode but suppose the card
collecting fantasy draft style team in
the diamond dynasty mode isn't your cup
of tea well that's fine because in that
case you can always hop into the several
other game modes offered in mlb the show
22 from classic exhibition matches
between current rosters to simulating a
proper franchise experience in franchise
mode there's also march to october which
always has been kind of like a franchise
light mode except this time around it's
getting some pretty beefy features for
starters march to october will span
multiple seasons now you'll be able to
take your team to a successful season
more than once before having to
transition it into a save in franchise
mode now this gives particularly newer
players a really nice entry point into
playing franchise mode without
overwhelming them while keeping the
march to october experience lengthy
trade logic has been adjusted and
improved upon in march to october as
well now when it comes to trade logic
there's a lot of information that really
only matters to more hardcore players
but the surface level adjustments are
basically adjusting how each baseball
player is valued the show refined trade
block logic to better reflect current
trends and now teams will value top
players by placing a premium on them
when negotiating trades for example some
teams will value relief or closing
pitchers less when compared to starting
position players or starting pitchers
additionally players will no longer be
traded immediately after signing in the
off-season in past that will be the show
games you could create customizable ball
players and take him on the road to the
show mode now both of those will return
with changes based on community feedback
so last year fans weren't really that
excited that you could only have one
customizable ball player which mlb the
show 22 addresses by completely removing
that cap instead of just one now you can
have up to 10 ball players with
different appearances positions and
various play styles such as archetypes
you can have ball players dedicate their
attributes to things like power contact
fielding and so on the show will also
have online co-op another first for the
series allowing players to partake in
2v2 and even 3v3 matches this
functionality even extends to diamond
dynasty letting you combine your card
collection with that of a friend for the
ultimate stacked team
one thing fans are always looking for
are new legends and the show 22
introduced some new additions to the
legends roster including randy johnson
and his kick-ass mustache and joe maurer
to name a few there's a full list
available online and be sure to let me
know in the comments which legend you
are most excited to see return
customization also takes some steps
forward as well as you are now no longer
restricted to only using existing mlb
teams like you were in the past this
time around march to october will have
full team customization options this
year letting you choose a custom name
access the logo vault and even use the
stadium creator ballpark lastly the game
will have a completely brand new
commentary team as well john buxiambi
and chris singleton will be joining the
game as the new play-by-play and color
commentary voices with thousands upon
thousands of lines of audio recorded
setting up a complete redesign of how
the game is called from game intros to
epic home run calls and even post play
analysis just to name a few there's also
an aim to make the commentary kind of
more conversational and natural where
the banner between the two commentators
are meant to feel more integrated in a
seamless way with the live action that
you will see of each game so many of
these changes are explored at length at
the sony san diego youtube channel so if
you've got that mlb itch and you can't
wait until launch be sure to check out
those conversations with ramon and the
rest of the team mlb the show 22 is out
on april 5th on xbox one xbox series snx
playstation 4 playstation 5 and the
nintendo switch
you'll have the option of grabbing the
standard edition mvp and digital deluxe
versions depending on your interests now
don't forget to stick with gamespot for
our upcoming review of mlb the show 22.
now here's a quick gameplay snippet of
me hitting a home run for you to enjoy
and that'll do it for me until next time
there's a swing and a drive
that's back
that one is gone
here's jed lowery
[Music]
you